[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend es
bahne sich eine Entscheidung an morgen
in Ramstein auch zu Kampfpanzern das
zumindest hat unser neuer
Bundesverteidigungsminister angekündigt
in dem Interview dass ich vorhin mit ihm
geführt habe
zuvor zeichnet unsere Korrespondent
Matthes Feldhoff den doch ziemlich
verrückten Tag nach den Doris Pistorius
heute absolviert hat morgens zur
Bundespräsidenten danach Vereidigung und
dann gleich Treffen mit
US-Verteidigungsminister Leuten seines
Zeichens ex-4-sterne-general und in
jeder Hinsicht eine mächtige Erscheinung
das Ganze im Angesicht eines
grauenhaften brandgefährlichen Krieges
in Europa und kaum übersehbarer
Konflikte innerhalb der NATO da konnte
man fast verstehen dass Amtsvorgängerin
Lambrecht heute geradezu erleichtert
wirkte den Job los zu sein
ein letztes Winken ein paar letzte Worte
ein letzter freundlicher Applaus damit
ist die Ära Lambrecht im
Verteidigungsministerium Geschichte und
Boris Pistorius übernimmt einen
politischen Trümmerhaufen nicht nur aber
auch von seiner Vorgängerin der größte
Teil der Zeitenwende meine Damen und
Herren liegt noch vor uns
die Streitkräfte das muss man leider
sagen sind in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten
oft vernachlässigt worden
diese Bundesregierung meine Damen und
Herren hat das beendet es ist ein neuer
Sound im Bendlerblock einer der sich
abhebt von seiner Vorgängerin dass die
nicht gerade taktgeberin war wird Boris
Pistorius bald einholen Lambrecht
hinterlässt manch erstaunliche Baustelle
gerade auch beim im letzten Jahrzehnt
eigentlich gewachsenen bundesweiter im
Jahr 2023 solle erstmals sinken
insgesamt um 300 Millionen nun kann man
das etwas kompensieren durch das
Sondervermögen von 100 Milliarden aber
es bleibt natürlich international nicht
unbemerkt am frühen Morgen beim
offiziellen Akt der Urkundenübergabe im
Präsidialamt steht ein griesgrämig
reinblickender Kanzler dabei und weiß
dass gerade das internationale Ansehen
auch mit seinem neuen Minister steht und
fällt der Bundespräsident spricht aus
was grundsätzlich selbstverständlich
aber konkret immer wieder umstritten ist
als starkes Land in der Mitte Europas
haben wir eine Verantwortung nicht nur
für uns sondern auch für andere wir
stehen nicht allein sondern im Bündnis
mit Partnern und diese Partner müssen
und werden sicher auf uns verlassen
kommt mit pistolius jetzt die
panzerwände bisher schweigt der Kanzler
zur Lieferung von Leopard Panzern an die
Ukraine doch der Druck wächst hier hat
heute erneut unter anderem Deutschland
zu einer internationalen panzerkoalition
aufgerufen dabei muss sich der Kanzler
vom ukrainischen Präsidenten ziemlich
persönlich kritisieren lassen ja zu
sagen ich liefere dann Panzer wenn
andere auch Panzer liefern und ich bin
mächtig in Europa und werde dann helfen
wenn jemand von außerhalb Europas hilft
ich glaube nicht dass das eine perfekte
Strategie ist damit sind wohl Berichte
gemeint Scholz habe vorgeschlagen sollte
Amerika Kampfpanzer liefern würde
Deutschland mitziehen ob der
US-Verteidigungsminister und sein neuer
deutscher Kollege darüber gesprochen
haben kann man vermuten zumindestens
haben sie sich heute getroffen konkretes
dazu aber mit keinem Wort
ich möchte der deutschen Regierung
danken für all das was sie zur Stärkung
der Ukraine getan haben während also
Pistorius und Austin hinter
verschlossenen Türen debattieren kündigt
im Bundestag ein SPD-Abgeordneter für
die morgige ramsteinkonferenz
substanzielle Beschlüsse an weil die
Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnen müsse für
sich und für uns
und dafür wird sie auch weitere
Kampfpanzer brauchen spricht da einer im
Namen des Kanzlers ist die
leopard-entscheidung intern schon
gefallen der Moment der Entscheidung für
Olaf Scholz rückt näher
und für den neuen
Bundesverteidigungsminister der uns aus
Berlin zugeschaltet ist guten Abend Herr
Pistorius guten Abend Frau Slomka ja was
ein Tag kaum ernannt mit der Urkunde in
der Hand dann das Treffen mit dem
mächtigsten Amtskollegen Austin wie ist
das Gespräch denn verlaufen haben Sie
den Eindruck da bahnt sich jetzt eine
Entscheidung an Stichwort Kampfpanzer
das könnte sein in der Tat das Gespräch
war war sehr offen und erfreulich wir
haben uns sehr gut verstanden auf
annehmen und wir haben uns vorgenommen
uns regelmäßig auszutauschen ich glaube
das ist auch wichtig in diesen Zeiten
einen engen Draht zu pflegen
Entscheidungen sind heute nicht gefallen
die werden an anderer Stelle getroffen
aber wir haben über alle Fragen der
transatlantischen Zusammenarbeit
gesprochen und das war wichtig und
notwendig nicht nur in Bezug auf die
Ukraine sie sagten gerade das könnte
sein also wurde auch über abrands und
Leopard 2 oder 1 gesprochen
wir haben überall diese Fragen im
vertraulichen Gespräch natürlich
gesprochen
aber im Wesentlichen im Rahmen eines
Austausches und eine Austausch der
Position die Gespräche laufen auf andere
Ebene 40 morgen vielleicht bis morgen
herausstellen welche Lösung es gibt aber
ich bleibe dabei wenn ich das sagen darf
wir haben sind sehr gut gefahren als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und als
Bündnispartner in den letzten 12 Monaten
dass die großen wichtigen Entscheidungen
zur Unterstützung der Ukraine immer im
transatlantischen Schulterschluss
getroffen worden sind und ich sehe
ehrlich gesagt keinen Grund warum man
davon ausgerechnet jetzt wenn es um
einen der größten und hochgerissenen
panzerkampfpanzer wie den Leopard 2 geht
anders sein sollte deswegen ist hier ein
konzertiertes Vorgehen ganz ganz wichtig
aber eine Einheit innerhalb der Europäer
wäre doch auch wichtig jetzt sieht so
aus die Briten liefern Kampfpanzer die
Fragen erst gar nicht mehr die Polen und
die finden sagen wir wollen unsere
Leoparden liefern die Deutschen müssen
jetzt bitte ja sagen und gibt's heute
auch noch diese Tallinn Initiative und
sich Großbritannien in Island die beiden
empfohlen und die Niederländer an die
Spitze gesetzt haben und Deutschland
steht irgendwie daneben
den Eindruck habe ich nicht der Eindruck
wird erweckt in der Tat aber tatsächlich
ist es so dass Deutschland zusammen mit
Großbritannien nach den USA der größte
Unterstützer der Ukraine in diesem
furchtbaren Krieg ist und in dieser
Rolle sehen wir uns tatsächlich auch für
die Zukunft aber das heißt nicht dass
man jede Entscheidung auch im Alleingang
treffen muss Bündnis Verpflichtung heißt
eben auch dass ein Bündnis
zusammenstehen muss und Entscheidungen
gemeinsam treffen muss und gemeinsame
Leistungen erbringen muss und um solche
Fragen muss es dann eben auch gehen und
wenn das dann ein paar Tage dauert dann
ist das so aber von der Landgang kann
doch gar keine Rede mehr sein der
Alleingang besteht doch jetzt eher darin
dass die Deutschen blockieren was andere
liefern wollen ja wir blockieren
zunächst mal nicht wir sagen man kann
über alles reden aber wir wollen den
transatlantischen Schulterschluss das
ist keine Blockade das ist der Weg zu
einem gemeinsamen Ziel das heißt da
geht's vor allen Dingen um die USA warum
ist es dem Kanzler warum ist es dann
jetzt künftig auch Ihnen als
Verteidigungsminister so wichtig dass
die Amerikaner da auch Kampfpanzer
liefern dass die mit dem Boot sitzen
weil sie die Sorge haben dass ich
Russland sonst vielleicht allein an
Deutschland rechnen würde
was heißt allein an Deutschland es gibt
um die Europäische Union es geht um
Mitteleuropa Großbritannien und
Frankreich sind atomare Mächte
Deutschland nicht es geht schlicht darum
dass wir die Sicherheit in der Balance
halten sowohl der Kanzler als auch ich
heute haben ein Eid geschworen Schaden
vom deutschen Volk abzuwenden das ist
unser Auftrag gleichzeitig haben wir
eine Bündnis Verpflichtung und beides in
Einklang zu bringen das ist unsere
Pflicht und das tun wir mit voller
Überzeugung aber wenn sie gerade darauf
hinweisen dass Deutschland keine Atom
macht ist heißt dass der Kanzler
vertraut nicht auf die NATO Strukturen
sondern er will dass die Amerikaner auf
jeden Fall auch Abrams liefern obwohl
die das eigentlich gar nicht wollen und
sagen zu können hallo Leute wir machen
das alle gemeinsam oder nein das habe
ich weder gesagt noch gemeint um Gottes
Willen der weder der Kanzlerin auch ich
stellen die Bündnis Verpflichtungen die
Einhaltung der Bündnis Verpflichtung und
die Bündnis treuen Fall diskutiert wird
aufgrund dieses Jungtier ja das kann
sein aber da muss ich dann denjenigen
die das tun auch umgekehrt unterstellen
dass das vielleicht nicht ganz rein
gewisses passiert denn jeder weiß dass
das nicht der Fall ist
die entscheidende Frage ist doch machen
wir so was alleine als Europäer als ein
Teil von Europa womöglich nur oder
machen wir es im Schulterschluss mit den
Amerikanern was immer das bedeutet dann
im Schulterschluss aber die Amerikaner
außen vorzulassen als den größten
Bündnispartner hielte ich in dieser
Frage eben auch für falsch aber was
heißt denn außen vor die Amerikaner
liefern jede Menge eventuell werden Sie
heute Abend oder morgen verkünden dass
sie auch an ein neues Waffensystem an
die Ukraine liefern präzisionsbomben mit
150 km Reichweite das wäre ein echter
gamechanger
mindestens so wichtig wie die
Kampfpanzer also es ist ja nicht so als
müsste man die Amerikaner jetzt noch
über diese Abrams unbedingt ins Boot
holen das muss doch nicht jeder das
selber liefern sondern die die am besten
was liefern können liefern oder ja das
stimmt aber wir reden wir reden über
einen kampfmann sowie den Leopard 2 der
eine der besten und auch
offensivtauglichsten ist den es gibt und
demzufolge ist es eben mit Vorsicht zu
genießen ihn jetzt einfach so
rauszugeben wir sind uns darüber im
Klaren dass er eine wichtige Rolle
spielen kann aber eben nicht nur er und
ich wiederhole mich die das atlantische
Vereinbarung die transatlantische
Zusammenarbeit hat einen eigenen
Stellenwert ich bin ziemlich sicher es
wird sehr bald zu einer Lösung kommen
sie sagten die Ukraine also noch jetzt
bevor Sie dieses Amt angetreten sind die
Ukraine muss gewinnen das muss man ja
dann auch definieren für die Ukraine
bedeutet gewinnen nicht dass die Dinge
jetzt so bleiben wie sie sind sondern
sie wollen ihr Territorium zurückerobern
und sehen wir bei allem was jetzt schon
geliefert wurde gerade im Osten gerade
dabei bachmut das sind grauenhaft
abnutzungs- und stellungskriege und um
diese zu durchbrechen bräuchte es ja das
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen also auch
mit Kampfpanzern die gehören damit dazu
sagen Militärs kann es sein dass die
deutsche Bundesregierung das bislang gar
nicht will eben weil sie fürchtet dass
Putin dann was immer auch macht wenn er
dann so ins Hintertreffen käme ich kann
das definitiv von nein das ist nicht die
Sorge der Bundesregierung uns geht es
darum ich kann das nur wiederholen dass
wir die Ukraine unterstützen wo immer
wir können niemand schließt aus das
Leopard Panzer geliefert werden können
oder dass die Genehmigung die Zustimmung
zu der Lieferung andere europäischer
Partner erteilt werden kann aber der bis
dahin sind noch nicht alle Fragen
beantwortet und das passiert gegenwärtig
ist aber interessant dass sie sagen
niemand schließt aus bisher war das
schon ziemlich ausgeschlossen das ist
mein Bild nicht es ist nur so gesagt zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht es ist keine
dauerhafte nach meinem Kenntnisstand
keine dauerhaft kein dauerhafter
Ausschluss einer solchen Möglichkeit
erfolgt ist mein Kenntnisstand
jedenfalls nicht die bewerten sie denn
dass die Polen sagen also wenn die
Deutschen sich nicht bewegen sinngemäß
dann liefern wir halt was wir wollen
dann machen wir das auch ohne Zustimmung
das wäre eine Entscheidung der
polnischen Regierung die ich dann
kommentieren würde wenn sie eintrete
tatsache ist aber es gibt bis heute
keinen Antrag weil meines Wissens
jedenfalls auferteilung einer solchen
Exportgenehmigung ist mein Stand von
heute morgen ist natürlich ein bisschen
formalistisch gesagt haben sie es
öffentlicher nun immer wieder und
ausdrücklich
ja gut aber wie gesagt wenn die Polen
sagen sie machen es ohne Genehmigung
dann wird man das Kommentieren wenn es
passiert hielt das nicht für besonders
Bündnis freundlich aber das sind dann
halt Dinge die passieren dafür sie leben
wir in Zeiten in denen es eben wirklich
unruhig ist und der ein oder andere dann
eben auch seine Rolle anders definiert
ich fasse noch mal zusammen wir können
damit rechnen dass morgen in Ramstein
doch entscheidendes verkündet wird kann
ich das so mitnehmen und unsere
Zuschauer ich hoffe darauf dann danke
ich Ihnen für das Gespräch sehr gerne
über den neuen Minister den Krieg und
die Zeitenwende diskutieren nachher auch
Maybrit Illner und Ihre Gäste jetzt
geht's aber erstmal bei dir weiter Heinz
in Frankreich brodelt es wieder da gibt
es Streiks ja und die richteten sich
gegen die geplante Rentenreform mehr als
eine Million Menschen sind auf die
Straße gegangen Teile des öffentlichen
Lebens waren lahmgelegt die meisten
Proteste verliefen friedlich allerdings
gab es auch Zusammenstöße mit der
Polizei und einige Festnahmen die
Beschäftigten sollen künftig statt mit
62 erst mit 64 in Rente gehen können
außerdem wäre die abschlagsfreie Rente
an eine Lebensarbeitszeit von 43 statt
bisher 42 Jahren gekoppelt Präsident
macron hält dies in einer immer älter
werdenden Gesellschaft für und
umgänglich Umfragen zu Folge lenen 60%
der Bevölkerung die Pläne ab
der Bundestag hat die systematische
Verfolgung und Ermordung von Jesiden
durch die terrormilizis als Völkermord
anerkannt seit 2014 vielen Tausende
Angehörige der vor allem in der
sinncharregion im Nordirak lebenden
jesidischen Minderheit den Gräueltaten
der Sie es zum Opfer wurden vertrieben
vergewaltigt ermordet noch heute fehlt
von etwa 3000 vermissten jede Spur
in Neuseeland hat Premierministerin hier
ein sinder nach mehr als fünf Jahren im
Amt überraschend ihren Rücktritt
angekündigt sie habe so sagte sie nicht
mehr genug im Tank für weitere Jahre als
Regierungschefin wurde 2017 mit nur 37
Jahren jüngste Ministerpräsidentin der
Welt machte vieles anders und
internationale Aufmerksamkeit erhielt
sie vor allem für ihr Krisenmanagement
in der Pandemie und den einfühlsamen
Umgang nach den Terroranschlägen von
Christchurch
die corona-sonderregelnden Unternehmen
sollen schon rund zwei Monate früher
wegfallen als geplant und zwar Anfang
Februar das geht aus einem
Referentenentwurf des
Bundesarbeitsministeriums für eine
Verordnung hervor besonders bisher
Entschuldigung bisher müssen Arbeitgeber
noch im Rahmen eines hygienekonzepts und
Testangebote für die Beschäftigten
prüfen
in Deutschland haben zum Ende des
vergangenen Jahres mehr Menschen als je
zuvor gelebt Grund ist die Zuwanderung
der Statistische Bundesamt schätzt die
Zahl der Menschen auf
84,3 Millionen fast 4 Millionen mehr als
vor zehn Jahren allein im vergangenen
Jahr kamen etwa 1,4 Millionen mehr
Menschen nach Deutschland als ins
Ausland weggezogen dem gegenüber stehen
allerdings weniger Geburten sowie mehr
Sterbefälle was das Bevölkerungswachstum
verlangsamt hat
die Pandemie habe gezeigt dass deutsche
Gesundheitssystem ist ein
schönwettersystem das sagt der
Sachverständigenrat Gesundheit der heute
sein Gutachten überreichte und übrigens
schon seit Jahren grundlegende Reformen
fordert und Vorschläge macht den der
Vergangenheit aber vielfach ungehört
Verhalten die Kernaussage ist also das
deutsche System ist nicht krisenfest was
Patienten gerade in den letzten Jahren
ja land auf Land ab am eigenen Leib
längst zu spüren bekamen als gerade
wieder in der Infektionswelle im Winter
bettenmangel Pflege Mangel überfüllte
Rettungsstation und manche Kliniken sind
finanziell jetzt schon am Ende Diana
Zimmermann Bericht
Spremberg gehört zu den ersten das
Krankenhaus in Südbrandenburg ist
insolvent zuletzt haben Corona und die
steigenden Energiepreise es geschwächt
Geschäftsführer Tobias Grundmann kämpft
das Haus wieder auf die Beine zu bringen
ihm hilft das Darlehen der Stadt die
Treue der Mitarbeiter und ein Plan die
große politische Richtung geht ja hin
vom stationären hin zum ambulanten und
auf diesen Weg begeben wir uns jetzt
quasi auch werden unsere vorhandenen
ambulanten Strukturen ausbauen und
parallel dazu versuchen in
sinnvollen Rahmen stationäre Strukturen
anzupassen so will Grundmann verhindern
was jedes dritte Krankenhaus fürchten
muss das Ende eine Insolvenzwelle läuft
an noch bevor die vom
Gesundheitsminister angekündigt der
Revolution im Krankenhauswesen begonnen
hat
Karl Lauterbach nämlich will eine
geordnete Gesundschrumpfung
Krankenhäuser sollen spezialisiert und
reduziert werden das soll Fachkräfte
freisetzen die Versorgung insgesamt
effizienter das Gesundheitswesen
widerstandsfähiger machen doch geordnet
ist bislang wenig der
sachverständigenratgesundheit und Pflege
hatte Ideen zur krankenhausreform schon
2018 unterbreitet heute stellte eine
ganze Latte neuer Anforderungen vor die
Analyse unverblümt die bisherige
Selbstwahrnehmung die wir als Deutsche
in Deutschland haben ist ja dass alles
gut organisiert ist und wir bestens auch
auf unvorhergesehene Entwicklung
vorbereitet sind das war und ist
allerdings trügerisch unser
Gesundheitssystem ist hochkomplex und
bei genauer Betrachtung ist es ein
behäbiges schönwettersystem
auf eine weitere Pandemie sei man nicht
vorbereitet die Digitalisierung
unzulänglich insgesamt müssten mehr und
genauere Daten gesammelt sicherer
gespeichert und besser genutzt werden
eine gefährliche Schwachstelle sehen die
Experten in der mangelnden Vorbereitung
auf den Klimawandel europäische
Nachbarländer setzen sich mit dem Thema
Hitze schon seit Jahren intensiv
auseinander und haben beispielsweise
landesweite verbindliche
hitzeaktionspläne damit Bürgerinnen und
Bürger aber auch die Menschen im
Gesundheitssystem wissen was man bei
Hitze tut der Gesundheitsminister
verspricht erste Hilfe bei Hitzewellen
mehr Personal aber das wichtigste ist
die Rettung der Krankenhäuser denn sonst
werden wir flächendeckend gerade auf dem
Land große Probleme haben so wie jetzt
schon in Spremberg in der mangelung
klarer Vorgaben aus der Politik wollen
Sie sich jetzt auf das ambulante und die
Psychiatrie konzentrieren um fit zu
werden für die Zukunft
die Vorstellung dass Dissidenten wenn
sie aus einer Diktatur flüchten im
ausländischen Exil dann einigermaßen
sicher sind ist ja leider naiv es gibt
genug Beispiele dafür wie der lange Arm
eines Regimes auch auf ausländischen
Boden zugreift man denke etwa an die
Gift und poloniumanschläge Russlands in
Großbritannien oder den Tiergarten Mord
in Berlin auch das iranische Regime
attackiert seine Kritiker auch dann wenn
Sie im Westen leben da werden Leute
gekidnappt und nach Iran verschleppt
oder bedroht wenn du nicht schweigst
dann rechnen wir uns an deiner
Verwandtschaft in der Heimat
so ergeht es auch einer iranischen
Oppositionellen in Paris sie hat Jörg
Brase erzählt wie perfide das abläuft
vor vier Jahren verließ Massi ca-marie
ihre Heimat Iran und lebt seitdem als
politischer Flüchtling in Paris seit
langem ist sie politisch aktiv erst den
Iran heute in Frankreich sie engagiert
sich in einer iranischen
Demokratiebewegung und unterstützt von
hier aus die Proteste im Iran
ich habe viele Informationen über das
brutale Vorgehen der Sicherheitskräfte
im Internet geteilt dass sie die
Menschen töten ich kann gegenüber den
Ereignissen nicht in different bleiben
ich hoffe dass mein Volk diese Regierung
loswerden kann
sie war auch bei Demonstrationen vor der
iranischen Botschaft in Paris dabei
schrie ihre Wut gegen das regimeteran
heraus diese Regierung versucht nun sie
zum Schweigen zu bringen und benutzt
dafür ihre im Iran lebenden Eltern als
Druckmittel Ende Dezember klingelte bei
denen das Telefon
wenn ihr heute nicht vorbeikommt werden
wir euch festnehmen sie hatten keine
Wahl meine Eltern sind also dorthin
gegangen jeder kennt die Adresse des
Geheimdienst Hauptquartiers in Teheran
ein berüchtigter Ort dort haben Sie das
Mobiltelefon meiner Mutter konfisiert
und dann gaben sie mir ein Ultimatum ich
müsste mich an dem Tag zwischen 19 und
22 Uhr bei Ihnen melden weil der Druck
auf meine Eltern so groß geworden war
habe ich an dem Abend schließlich die
Nummer meiner Mutter angerufen
dieses Gespräch hat sie aufgezeichnet
und sie entschied sich damit an die
Öffentlichkeit zu gehen wenn wir uns
einschüchtern lassen und Schweigen sagt
sie dann wird sich nie etwas ändern hier
ein kurzer Auszug aus dem Gespräch
jede ihrer Handlungen in Frankreich
gegen die islamische Republik sind ein
Verbrechen wir werden Ihre Familie in
Iran dafür zur Verantwortung ziehen
nirgendwo auf der Welt werden Familien
für ein Verbrechen in Sippenhaft
genommen aber hier machen wir das so
wenn Sie glauben ich hätte ein
Verbrechen begangen bitten Sie doch
Interpol mich festzunehmen das hat
nichts mit der Polizei zu tun wir werden
ja sehen wer am Ende dafür bezahlt Ende
dieser Woche wird ihre Familie ins
Gefängnis wandern sie bedrohen mich
schon wieder
ein Regime das seine Bürger bedroht
festnimmt foltert tötet rund 19.000
Festnahmen gab es im Zusammenhang mit
den Protesten bisher vier Todesurteile
wurden vollstreckt sich gegen dieses
Regime aufzulehnen dazu gehört Mut
ich habe versucht stark zu sein am Ende
habe ich gesagt ich werde nicht tun was
ihr von mir verlangt ich werde euch
nicht mehr zuhören ich werde mich euren
Drohungen nicht beugen aber es war sehr
sehr hart
das ist jetzt zwei Wochen her noch hat
sich der Geheimdienst Mann nicht mehr
gemeldet doch jede Minute kann das
Telefon klingeln fürchtet Massi ca Marie
die Nachricht dass ihre Eltern für den
Proteste Tochter büßen müssen doch ich
habe keine Wahl sagt sie ich muss reden
auch wenn es mir das Herz bricht
nach Deutschland Post zu empfangen das
könnte in den nächsten Tagen schwierig
werden damit geht's jetzt bei dir weiter
im Tarifstreit bei der Deutschen Post
hat die Gewerkschaft Verdi die
Beschäftigten in allen Brief und
paketzzentren bundesweit zu Streiks
aufgerufen und zwar bereits heute nach
der zweiten Verhandlungsrunde und auch
für morgen bei reale gibt es schon einen
ersten Überblick wo und in welchem
Umfang gestreikt wird nun
streitmeldungen kommen aus allen
Landesteilen viele Briefkästen dürften
deshalb morgen leer bleiben tausende
Päckchen und Pakete die ja eigentlich
über Nacht sortiert werden sollen werden
werden nicht in die Postautos verladen
die Folgen des Streiks dürften also die
nächsten Tage überall zu spüren sein
noch herrscht hier am Abend in einer
Frankfurter Filiale business as usual
das könnte morgen schon ganz anders
aussehen die Gewerkschaft verdi hat alle
Brief und paketzen der Post zum Streik
aufgerufen weitere Arbeitsniederlegungen
in den nächsten Tagen würden folgen 15
Prozent mehr lohnfördert die
Gewerkschaft für die Postangestellten
Laufzeit 12 Monate laut Verdi hat der
überwiegende Teil der Postmitarbeiter
ein niedriges Einkommen von 160.000
Mitarbeitern bekommen 140.000 ein Monats
Grund Entgelt von
2108 bis 3.090 € brutto die Deutsche
Post DHL ist hochprofitabel den
Löwenanteil ihrer Gewinne aber erzielt
sie im Ausland in Deutschland macht der
Post vor allem das schrumpfende
Briefgeschäft zu schaffen die Post hatte
die Gehaltsforderung der Gewerkschaft
bereits mehrfach als realitätsfern
abgewiesen bei einer Zeit weil ich
zweistelligen Inflationsrate scheint die
Forderung aber gar nicht so weit
hergeholt
vielen Dank
bei der Handball WM ist das deutsche
Team mit einem klaren Sieg in die
Hauptrunde gestartet 39 zur 19 stand es
am Ende gegen Argentinien damit hat die
Mannschaft von Trainer gieslersson einen
weiteren Schritt Richtung Viertelfinale
gemacht nächster Gegner ist am Samstag
das Team der Niederlande und der Spiel
ist hier im ZDF zu sehen Sportstudio
live am Samstagabend ab
20:15 Uhr bei den Australian Open ist
Laura Siegemund in die dritte Runde
eingezogen die 34-Jährige setzte sich
gegen die Rumänien Irena Camelia bego in
drei Sätzen durch und es damit die
letzte verbliebene deutsche Spielerin im
Turnier Olympias dagegen scheiterte bei
seinem Grand Slam Comeback nach schwerer
Verletzung in der zweiten Runde er
verloren vier Sätzen gegen Michael more
aus den USA
im Fußball richtet sich die
Aufmerksamkeit einmal mehr auf Rudi
Völler er wird zum ersten Februar neue
Direktor der Männer-Nationalmannschaft
es gibt nur ein Rudi Völler
die Fans haben es schon immer geahnt
Rudi Völler altbekanntes Gesicht im
deutschen Fußball soll neuer halsbringer
fürs ramponierte Image der nationalelden
mal wieder wie schon vor 23 Jahren als
er die da niederliegende
Nationalmannschaft als Teamchef übernahm
und schließlich ins WM Finale 2002
führte ein Mann dem selbst nach em aus
und Rücktritt 2004 die Sympathien weiter
zuflogen na klar Weltmeister war Völler
ja schließlich schon als Spieler Rom
1990 der langjährige Sportdirektor in
Leverkusen seit Sommer im Ruhestand
plötzlich wieder Hoffnungsträger ein
populärer gegen Entwurf zum allmächtigen
ehemaligen Sportdirektor Oliver Bierhoff
dessen Part bei der Männer
Nationalmannschaft Völler übernimmt Rudi
nationale der 62-Jährige eigentlich
schon Rentner nicht die innovativste
nicht die kreativste Lösung aber er kann
sofort helfen und er soll mit seiner ihm
typischen Art für
Sympathiepunkte sorgen für ein nahbares
Image und das brauchen der DFB und die
Nationalmannschaft dringend und er muss
auch für einen Aufbruch Sorgen denn mit
einem weiter so geht es nicht weiter vor
zwei Tagen schon für sein Lebenswerk
geehrt versucht sich der einstige
Stürmer nun bis zum Heimspiel bei der
Europameisterschaft 2024 als
flankierende Offensivkraft fürs
Nationalteam
[Applaus]
s gleich geht's wie schon gesagt weiter
und um 0:30 Uhr meldet sich den
Christopher Wehrmann mit unserem heute
schnell Update und morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend das hier ist unser Wolken
Regen und Schnee vorschaufeln der Schnee
ist bei uns rosa und der Regen blau
eingefärbt sie sehen hier das ist heute
Nacht noch etwas schneit in Deutschland
und morgen kommt der neue Schnee hier im
Westen auf der zieht dann südwestwärts
weg und dann kommt der Schnee aus Osten
am Samstag in der Nacht zu Sonntag und
Sonntag über Tage bereitet er sich hier
aus von Sachsen bis zum Bodensee und in
der Nacht zum Montag kann es dann hier
in der Lausitz schon wieder erneut
schneiden aber mal der Reihe nach heute
Nacht fällt kaum Schnee zum Teil dass
der Himmel auch klar es bildet sich mal
etwas Nebel an der Nordsee reicht
vielleicht mal für ein Gewitter das wird
eine eisige Nacht die Temperaturen auf
plus ein bis minus zehn Grad das
bedeutet natürlich auch wieder
Straßenglätte und morgen bleibt es
dauert frostig in Bayern mit
Temperaturen zwischen 0 und -3 Grad
etwas milder wird's am Main und am Rhein
+4 Grad das wird ein recht freundlicher
Freitag morgen sondern Wolken wechseln
sich ab in Schleswig-Holstein ist einige
schneeregenschauer und an den alten
schneits nachmittags kommt dann dieses
angesprochene neue kleine tief heran das
wieder Schnee bringt jetzt aktuell
liegen ja in den Mittelgebirgen zum Teil
15 bis 30 cm Schnee Cottbus meldete
heute morgen 10 cm bis morgen Abend wird
sich an dieser Schnee Lage kaum was
ändern aber dann bis zum Sonntag da
breiten sich die Schneeflächen aus da
könnten hier in Sachsen in Thüringen 5
bis 40 cm Schnee liegen und das ist doch
schon mal eine ganze Menge am Montag
streiten die Sonne über dem neue Schnee
guten Abend